hello everyone and welcome to another
special game from round 7 of this year's
Global chess League it is rihad Rapport
versus gookish and it's a beautiful
beautiful Joko piano game you guys will
enjoy it and I um well I I kept
wondering uh just how much uh Rapport
and ding prepared The Joker piano for
the world cheers championship match
because of course you know that the ding
opened his games with either C4 or D4 he
played the uh either some sort of a
Queen's Gambit setup or or he went for
the English and uh he he did not play
e41 so they did not prepare uh the the
Italian game with the white pieces but
Nepal was an E4 player he played E4 in
all of the games and even though an
apple did go for the Roy Lopez in In all
the game all of them uh I'm sure uh they
did prepare the Joker piano uh because
well what do you know maybe nepo will
will go for the Italian game at some
point so uh if you remember what Fabiana
corvana said uh during uh well not
during after his Russian championship
match against Magnus he said that okay
he didn't use all of his preparation
during the world's championship match
but maybe he had enough preparation to
you know play any any tournament uh and
he will crush everyone and then maybe
you know in a few tournaments after that
he will have some leftover preparation
from the World Chess Championship match
so uh what ding knows uh for his
wheelchair championship match against
Nepal you can be sure the Rapport knows
and I'm very interested to see what they
have prepared for or against the The
Joker piano so let's check it out we
have pawned the E4 by rapper Pawn D5 by
gookish Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
Bishop to C4 we have Bishop to C5 and no
we do not see the Evans Gambit here we
have C3 the main line of the Joker piano
and uh well uh let's see uh uh let's see
what the what he or they prepared Knight
to F6 with Pawn to D3 Pawn to D6 and now
castles this is the absolute main line
and here A6 is the top move but gugish
plays Pawn to A5 this is like the fifth
or sixth most popular idea but it has
been played quite a lot by none other
than Magnus Carlsen and Magnus never
lost a game I wouldn't say five move and
uh of course you understand why A5 is
played to stop Pawn to B4 White's
strongest move in any position and of
course you want to play a for A3 and
then uh well undermine White's Queen
side so okay uh and the Magnus played he
played against dude that he played
against nepo he played it against Wesley
he played it against wrestling topalov
so yeah it's it's a a very good move we
have Rook the E1 uh we have Pawn to H6
and Knight B to D2 We have castles and
pawn to H3 so fairly standard uh uh
Italian game moves uh we have A4 and now
Knight to F1 the Knight is coming to G3
with Bishop to D7 and pawn to D4 uh with
Bishop to B6 and Knight the G3 so again
uh all standard moves rook d8 and now uh
there is there are a couple games that
we you this position there's even a game
that I covered in 2018 uh Fabiana
kurwana played it against the ziadizoria
where Fabi continued with Bishop to F1
but Fabi lost that game in case you
haven't seen it do check it out it's uh
from my old apartment with my old setup
and you can see Meadow a meadow sleeping
in the uh back on the couch it will be
the first thing in the description below
if you also want to check that out but
okay here we have Rook to E2 it's a new
move so now as of move 13 we have a
completely new position
uh or a completely new game uh now the
idea is of course you want to add more
protection to the F2 pawn and the
black's uh main idea here is to play
Queen to B8 Queen to A7 and now you
already have the F2 Pawn defended so
it's uh you know it's definitely a nice
move and you can now develop the queen
develop the bishop you can maybe double
up on the file so very uh you know just
a lot of ideas here uh Queen to B8 the
googish continues with this plan with
Bishop to E3 and now e captures on D4
now you can't capture with the c Pawn
because the E4 Pawn is hanging you have
to play Bishop capture Sandy for now the
Knight and Rook are nicely defending the
pawn and Knight captures on D4 we have C
captures and now Bishop to C6 and here
okay you have the standard trade-off of
white has the strong Knights white has
the strong Center black has the mighty
Bishops pair and if this bishop pair
becomes fully operational uh then well
it's no mystery how this game will end
so Pawn to E5 and not allowing Lucas to
continue with any of his plans and now
what you do here do you capture or do
move the Knight well point is if you
capture it's actually playable but you
know it's a really weird line D captures
D captures now Bishop captures on F3 so
you have to give up one of your Bishops
and now after G captures you play C6
that's the point now you cannot capture
the Knight because of Queen characters
and G3 the F2 Pawn is pinned and you
have to play something like F4 but even
with the slightly ruined Vikings
position yeah you still have the strong
Center black loss the bishop pair so
white is the one to be preferred here so
after E5 we have Knights the D5
gookishes I'm not giving up the bishop
pair just for that uh Rook to E4 and
it's no mystery where this Rook is
headed The Rook is of course headed to
G4 and there it will put pressure on
Black's uh King side with Queen to d8
the queen now wants to help out with the
defense of the king and Rook to G4 with
King date moving the King off of the G
file and now the immediate Knight to F5
just going after that G7 pawn and how
can gookish defend this well it's not
gonna easy and there's no great move for
black here Gucci opts for Bishop to D7
which asks the question what what are
you even doing here I'm gonna attack
your your knight and if you move it I'm
gonna pick up your Rook
and here a report could just prepare the
attack with Knight 3 to H4 but he
doesn't he goes for Knight captures and
G7 right away and he offers The Rook on
G4 for the rook and EA and should you
play this well it seems that this is the
best course of action for Google but he
did not play it I'll just quickly show
it Bishop captures on G4 Knight captures
here and now if you go for an all-out
trade let's say uh Bishop captures Queen
captures now Queen captures and E8 you
finish by capturing the Knight on D5 and
now the F7 Pawn is saying that's the
problem the B7 Pawn is hanging that's
not a problem and also Queen to F6 check
followed by E6 is another problem and
you cannot Parry all of these threats
maybe with some you know super engine
Precision you can defend this and not
lose but I I seriously doubt it so
instead gookers does not go for this he
goes for Rook to G8 uh sorry about that
he goes for Rook to G8 and now we have
Queen to D2 now uh Queen to D2 might not
be the most optimal uh setup Rook the H4
is the most optimal setup here but we
have to remember this is a rapid game so
you don't have time to analyze uh you
know during the game but I will just
show why the point is that you prepare
Queen to D2 with Rook to H4 as it comes
with the threat of capturing on H6 and
after King captures now you play Bishop
captures on D5 and after black plays
animal let's say C6 now you have Queen
to D2 but now Queen to D2 is different
because it comes with the threat of
Checkmate so it's a slight Improvement
so okay Queen to D2 right away we have
Rook captures and G7 and now again Rook
DH for uh is is the move but a rapper
trades right away Rook captures we have
King captures and Bishop captures on D5
they were both playing really fast like
none of them were in time travel at any
point in the game so here Pawn to C6 D
captures on E5 is the move that you have
to play but C6 was played by gukesh and
now he allows even Bishop captures on F7
and up or just you know continuous
merely sacrificing pieces and uh this
isn't even a peace sacrifice because if
you capture Queen captures on H6 and now
you are up three pawns that's I mean
that's a lot you can even trade
everything and go for the end game you
will have three points uh for example
against the bishop and you are very
happily playing that end game uh of
course it will not come to that because
white will uh you know utilize his
Advantage before it comes to that but uh
you know it's not it's not the best uh
instead of this bookish played Queen to
E7 again you should capture an E5 at
least once but he played uh Queen to E7
and now a rapid is completely winning
but only if you find one very specific
idea so feel free to pause the video and
to win the game for Rehab while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that we
need to open up this diagonal for the
White Queen in order to win and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Ponte E6 that's the move and
the idea is of course next we play Pawn
to D5 we open up this diagonal and it's
a game over for the black king so uh
it's not possible to defend this gookash
tries one idea and that is Bishop
captures and E6 this stops D5 for the
moment because after Bishop captures and
queen captures okay now you don't really
have any use of playing D5 right away
but Robert finds a way uh Queen to B4
the bishop is attacked and if you move
the bishop then the B7 Pawn Falls and
you cannot defend the bishop the queen
cannot defend the bishop you only uh the
only way to defend the bishop is Rook D6
but that's a very passive move to play
it is the strongest move to play just a
very passive one so gookish forced to
play it and now comes Rook to E1 that
gets The Rook into the game with Tempo
The Queen Is Now attacked we have Queen
to F6 and now without any further
preparation Pawn to D5 not caring about
the pawn because you've now you have
Rook D6 you have prepared Queen to G4
also can come now that the the fourth
rank has been cleared and there's just
no escaping all of the threats here
gookish capture than D5 but now Queen to
G4 with check King to f8 and now Queen
to C8 with check with Bishop to d8 and
now of course uh well I don't have to
tell you the winning move you all see it
and the black queen is the only piece
defending the bishop on d8 and uh Knight
is covering H4 G5 and discovered by The
Rook discovered by the queen so you you
merely have to move the black Queen off
of the F6 square and you accomplish that
by Rook D6 this is where rapper played
uh and he was in this position on move
33 that gookish resigned as there is
nothing more to be done here so truly a
marvelous example of
um uh utilizing the the main line of the
Joker piano instead of going for the
Evans Gambit C3 just completely
obliterating gookish and no doubt it's
uh it's uh some of the leftovers from
the world's championship match even
though it has not been employed even
once as nepo played like I said the
Royal Lopez in every game uh but uh I
mean of course of course they prepared
at least something against this line
that's why uh he he probably knows it
all too well uh because you you can't uh
you know come to the World Chess
Championship match and not prepare uh
for the Joker piano or against at least
against the Joker piano uh it's been
played ever since you know the days of
uh Greco and it's been played in pretty
much all the all the matches in history
in all the World Series Championships so
you always have to prepare it it doesn't
matter how strong the engines get uh we
we are never escaping you know at the
The Joker piano uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it very
nicely uh played by by Rapport and I
think Rapport is currently top 10 uh In
classical chess and gookish is all the
way up to number 13 uh but in Rapid
chess Rapport is actually number seven
in the world and I don't know Google is
okay he's a bit overrated and Rapid um
I'm guessing he just didn't play as uh
as many rapid games because he is of
course much stronger than 26-29 uh but
that's why if he continues winning you
know he will he will gain that rating uh
so yeah that's the game really hope you
guys enjoyed it uh I would like to thank
Thomas vetterly uh Jim Meadow Tool uh
Federico Torres Velasco uh Dan McCormick
and James Eugene Cashman for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful chess league and whatever else
happens in the Chess World while
checking out your wonderful suggestions
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day